you know when my daughter was wrestling
trying to make it through to state her
first day she lost a match so my
daughter she knows that you know that
night she's thinking
she if she loses one match she's not
going to stay in there's her senior year
right and she was underweight she loses
she doesn't even talk to me on the way
back to the hotel room she's just
angry you know she's still underweight
but she goes out the next day and like i
saw a little look in her face that was
like it's not over yet and
she won her first match and you could
see almost
like a vibe coming over and then she won
her next match and she won an x-max and
then
her toughest match of the day where in
brawley and she's wrestling against a
girl from brawley then my daughter won
that attitude of it's not over yet yeah
but it's not over yeah and to have that
attitude with life
that's a little lesson learned for
everybody today
you